hello and welcome to hot tip the show
right there controversial stance and
tried to justify it today I wanted to
talk about the old Dragon Ball movies
and why I didn't like them but then I
had an idea now you see through
childhood even adulthood whenever a
Dragon Ball movie popped onto my screen
I either gave it a shot and didn't like
it or avoided it entirely which resulted
in me not having seen many of the major
Dragon Ball films and so I decided to
give you guys the opportunity that
changed my mind about a week ago I sent
out a tweet asking you guys this
question what are your three favorite
Dragon Ball films that came out before
battle of gods having received a
surprising number of comments I compiled
all of them have found the four most
recommended Dragon Ball films from you
guys coming in at number four with 10%
of the total votes comes Bojack unbound
number three with 11.6 percent of the
total comes coolers revenge slotting and
falling just short of the top spot at
number two is wrath of the Dragon at
fifteen point four percent and the
number one most favored old Dragon Ball
film with 25 point four percent of the
total votes comes Fusion reborn and so
before I knew it my journey began in
earnest I waited patiently as my
computer legally acquired exactly ninety
three point seven gigabytes of Dragon
Ball movies once this entirely legal Act
had been completed I began my campaign
with coolers revenge after siphoning
through all of the votes in the comments
section one film I was surprised to see
show up as often as it did was this film
I had never seen it before and so went
in with enthusiasm and to be perfectly
honest it was okay I had problems with
it but the movie had some interesting
choices and moments I did not see coming
the most interesting part of the film
for me was actually its middle section
because Cooter's men who are basically
the ginyu force are all equipped with
Scouters Crillon and Gohan needed to
keep their power levels as low as
possible in order to keep them away from
Goku who at this time is barely hanging
on due to an injury sustained from
cooler however the interesting part is
in keeping their power levels this low
escaping from rockslides becomes
dangerous lifting boulders becomes very
difficult and flying well that's
impossible without wings that is
thankfully go on has a pet dragon that
grants him the ability to fly to corns
Tower
to retrieve some sense of beans that
Goku desperately needs I really enjoyed
this bit specifically and the piccolo
fight that follows is honestly the
highlight of the entire movie for me in
terms of action but I suppose my biggest
complaint comes with the character of
Kuler himself and the liberties this
short film takes with the character of
Goku cooler is honestly all the most
boring parts of Frieza within none of
the creativity and Goku whoa boy if
you're one of those people that think
Funimation are solely responsible for
turning Goku into Superman watch this
film Toei animation bypass Superman
entirely and go straight for Jesus in
this film Goku is like Jesus now with
that said I have no issue with having a
positive environmental message in fact I
like it but to frame it like this where
go COO is suddenly concerned with the
lives of all these animals the landscape
and even bringing them back to life from
the brink of death as if he were Jesus
is a step at least too far for me
especially when you consider the amount
of destruction he's caused in the search
of a good fight throughout the entire
series as for the action a site from the
piccolo fight I was honestly a little
underwhelmed this may be due to the fact
that I just got done watching the Broly
movie last week but I think more than
that what this film lacked was
originality the majority of the action
is a less visually impressive rehash of
Goku's fight with Frieza with too many
of the same elements to be considered
unique and I think that's the biggest
issue I had with this movie it felt like
a longer than average TV episode that
has nothing to do with the story and
sort of mess with the characters a
little to achieve its goals no cure did
have some extremely cool moments that
were unique to him like when he cut
through the Kamehameha but to be honest
they were few and far between
kut'rs motivations in this film seemed
extremely contrived too he was
determined to search the forest for Goku
because he wanted to be the one to end
him personally straight-up refusing to
blow up the planet because he thought
that would cheapen it but what does he
do at the end try to blow up the planet
that Goku Zahn it really doesn't make
sense unless I assume cooler is exactly
the same as Frieza
in terms of personality which I wouldn't
know because he basically has two scenes
in this entire movie with that said
there are tons of aspects to like about
this film as I said I really enjoyed the
middle section and I loved some of the
character moans it doesn't overstay its
welcome and when it does do something
different it's great and
action is smooth and nostalgic and even
some of the callbacks were charming all
in all better than I expected it to be
but I wouldn't be running back to see it
anytime soon and so next up is Bojack
this movie is bananas but strangely
enough doesn't give me a lot to talk
about it's just a tournament that sort
of gets out of hand really I personally
enjoy tournament toxin anime maybe more
than the average person but going into
this movie I was led to believe that
this was going to be a Gohan film yet
the entire first half could be seen as a
Crillon mini movie seeing as most of the
events that take place are from his
perspective however with this film being
called Bojack unbound I was really
surprised to find that bojack doesn't
show up until over halfway through this
film which is surprisingly when the film
nosedives for me King Kai monologues
about Bojack basically telling us his
backstory a backstory that seems way
more interesting than this exposition
dumped by the time Bojack and the gang
are lined up and ready to fight the
occasion doesn't have any sort of
emotion behind it we know nothing about
bojack's personality his past apart from
what King Kai has monologue dat us and
all in all it just feels like the most
forced interaction why would they have
come to earth because there it's
beautiful yeah okay I mean it's really
cool seeing Gohan at this age fighting
but after what happened with cell white
can t just go super saiyan 2 now you see
this is an issue because the villains in
this film are sort of void of
personality because they haven't been
given that development and so the film
rests on the character go on a character
that gets a ton of his best qualities
based on the villains he fights see the
problem here and so because the villains
are nothing of interest really
everything feels either forced padded or
boring to me Gohan is easily the most
likeable character in Dragon Ball yet I
really didn't like Gohan in this movie
he doesn't know thing in the film
besides wait watch get saved
FlightAware his friends are being beaten
up and repeats this until the end where
he too gets beaten up until Goku through
the power of deus ex machina saves the
day by slapping some sense into it
why did you need to be told that to be
honest while beautiful this plays out
extremely heavy handedly with zero
emotional investment primarily due to
the superficial stakes the villains and
the convenience with which Gohan forgot
what he was fighting for in the end this
movie feels very confused
despite it starting with a very simple
format by the time Bojack and the rest
of the gang show up I honestly have no
idea what the movie was trying to make
me feel decides more of what the cell
saga did better the first half enjoys a
light-hearted tournament structure
centered around what feels like thrillin
and it's honestly the best part of the
movie for me with that said I understand
loads of people loved this movie because
of its gorgeous visuals and fantastic
action sequences but for me action for
actions sake is never going to interest
me at all and will actually ultimately
bore me there needs to be an emotional
story behind something like this
especially when you're talking about a
character as emotionally driven as
Gauhar all in all in this movie
especially in the second half things
happen for questionable and contrived
reasons and honestly the pasting is all
over the place there are some great
visuals but that's never going to be
enough for me to enjoy a movie I'm
afraid unfortunately this is exactly the
sort of movie I was expecting all of
these movies to be just empty action
sequences now on to the second most
recommended film wrath of the Dragon
this was actually an interesting movie
and it's a completely new and unique
story to this film it begins as Vidal
and Gohan and fight crime when they come
across this old fella who foresees the
end of the world if all seven
dragonballs are not gathered naturally
the balls are gathered in a quirky and
character rich way that feels extremely
Dragonball I wish is made to release
this hero from a music box
the result is tachyons release and the
theme that accompanies him is
spectacular and incredibly catchy
instantly becoming one of my all-time
favorite Dragonball tunes no small feat
I absolutely adore it
as for tapi on himself for having just
being introduced his character is
actually very interesting ignoring his
great visual design I think he fits
perfectly within the story that's being
told here with the Z warriors
specifically with Trump's touted as a
great hero trunks wants to help tap
Young who has isolated himself for
reasons that are still unknown to the
viewers the forces that cause both
trunks and Tapie on to interact are
Ganic and believable making for a
genuinely emotional relationship we
learned that tapi on holes within him a
great burden a monster that has shown up
several times in the story thus far that
is intrinsically attached to him he
alone must play this song to keep the
monster at bay meaning he cannot sleep
at his release from that box was to the
detriment of the universe trumps on the
other hand wants to help tap Eon as a
child the label hero is hard to ignore
and what's more it makes sense that
trunks wishes to have an older brother
figure like Goten has with Gohan it's
honestly sort of touching as trunks
breaks down tap Ian's walls and proves
himself capable to him however at the
halfway point there's tons of exposition
dropped now it is delivered in a fine
way but it's again an example of a story
that would benefit greatly from having a
longer format the tale its narrative
these films are only 50 minutes each
this could have easily been made into a
series of episodes or even a 90-minute
feature these 50-minute time restraints
on these films act as a stranglehold on
the stories they are trying to tell as
we approach the end of the film the
monster is released from tapi on
destroying the city we get some great
action sequences with the main cast
including Vegeta who has been
inexplicably absent throughout the film
despite these efforts however all of our
heroes are down for the count
except one tap yun takes center stage
playing his ocarina successfully sealing
away the monster within his body before
falling to the floor screaming in agony
it is then we get the best scene of the
film after spending the entire story
working on the relationship between
trunks and his hero from another time
tapi on in desperation tells trunks one
of the only people he trusts that's the
only way to stop this monster within him
is four trunks to kill him using this
sword which while being a uniquely dark
moment in Dragonball that's definitely
earned also acts as a potential origin
for the blade Future Trunks uses retro
actively giving more weight to the
actions he carried out with that blade
earlier in the series it's honestly a
fantastic scene but naturally trunks
couldn't bring himself to do it
it's just too much to drop at a young
kid that soon now what would have made
logical sense in this moment would have
been four trunks to realize that he
missed his only chance to save everyone
and through great struggle gets in
position to stop the monster again pert
a peons request killing him to save the
day but instead the move
literally tanks its entire narrative in
the final moments while the move Goku
did in Super Saiyan 3 was cool he had
literally nothing to do with this movie
the movie was about trunks and Tapie on
and maybe go on to a much lesser extent
I loved what this movie was doing up
until this last scene and honestly it
ruins the goodwill I had at the last
hurdle it's such a disappointing ending
Fusion reborn was by far the most highly
voted in the comments so much so that
are actually trended in the US after I
sent out that tweet asking you guys this
question so that's pretty cool needless
to say I had high expectations for this
movie and after seeing it I gotta say I
actually really liked it this story is
very very simple and I think that's a
great thing with a runtime of only 50
minutes it benefitted greatly from not
having to juggle too many characters
motivations and plot lines instead of
doing that this film has to plot lines
the earth plotline and the main other
worlds plot line these two scenes are
happening simultaneously and they
motivate each other while Goku is
fighting in an other world tournament
one of the workers at the check-in
station breaks something and as a result
releases all of the souls contained
within other world thus bridging the gap
between the living and the dead it's an
interesting premise to say the least an
Otherworld happens to be my favorite
Dragon Ball settings so it's right up my
alley
because of this accident in Otherworld
Goku and PyCon are forced to deal with
this issue directly while the fighters
of Earth are forced to face off against
some of Dragon Balls greatest villains
though it's not without its bad moments
the fight that takes place in Otherworld
is honestly refreshing and fun at the
beginning before turning dangerous and
thrilling by the end Regina shows up to
make the save and because of the
established check-in station mistake it
makes perfect sense that he shows up
here to make that save Ginetta as a
villain is exactly what this movie
needed and is everything I wanted majin
buu to be in the cannon story earned was
an incredible move set and a ruthless
personality he is an overwhelming force
of nature to deal with and a memorable
I've criticized these films in the past
for being too similar to their Canon
saga counterparts and while this film
does the same thing in trying to mirror
the Majin Buu saga I think it succeeds
because unlike the other arcs of
Dragonball that Majin Buu saga left a
lot to be desired and that's putting it
mildly now with that said
our aspects of this movie I really
didn't enjoy and I'm sure I'm not the
only one here the second half of the
earth subplot was awful
you know when Hitler shows up for some
reason the artwork in this section is
much more stylized than the rest of the
film and honestly just doesn't flow with
the rest of the story's visuals at all I
understand that this section is there to
add levity to the film but with the
fusion between Vegeta and Goku handling
a large portion of that levity this
section really didn't serve a purpose
for me at all ignoring this because the
story made sense was kept simple and all
introductions were consistent with its
established logic I was able to enjoy
the visuals in action to a much greater
degree than I had with any of the other
films it's beautiful
action-packed and a genuinely fun ride
beginning to end definitely the best old
Dragon Ball movie I have ever seen and
those are my thoughts in these films do
you agree or do you think I miss
something was your favorite Dragon Ball
film from the 90s on here let me know
down below in the meantime I'm gonna go
sleep that I'll do for this week thank
you so much for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]